Robin is with us in Philadelphia hi
Robin how are you hi Dave pleasure to
talk to you you too what's up I wanted
your thoughts on adult children still
living at home should they pay rent or
should they not I think I know what
you're going to say but I need
validation they need a plan for exit
well they're still my one is going to be
going back to school in September and my
daughter who just graduated with her
associates is hemming and hawing about
going back next spring and how old is
she she's 22 okay well maybe she needs
to move out well we have started
charging her rent that one what I said
yeah I know I can how do you just do
that though I mean I can't no you don't
just do that but you need to make a plan
to do that they need to leave because
you eventually because she's him and and
hawin that tells me that we're stunting
her emotional growth it's time for her
to start making some grown-up decisions
and so darling regardless of what you do
we need to have you out of here in six
months and let's start developing a plan
to do that if you want to pay me rent
but during the six months and I'll give
it back to you at the end of the six
months you can use it as a savings
account here that's fine but you're
going to be on a budget while you're
here and you're going to be working a
job while you're here you're going to be
paying your own way for everything and
you're going to be looking at apartments
and finding out what electricity costs
and looking for a roommate because
you're going to need all of those mm-hmm
yes she does pay her own way she does
have a job she does all that it's just
we thought it was time that we started
charging them rent to teach
responsibility not that we need the
money but we wanted to teach them you
know I don't really want to teach them
responsibility to say I want to believe
I know I do want them to leave yeah
which teaches them responsibility by the
way let me tell you what happened at our
house okay all three of ours one of ours
got married before college graduation
and so she moved straight in with her
new husband after before graduation and
after graduation which was good that's
Rachel right on Winston got married six
months before Rachel graduate
Denise graduated moved home for three
months Daniel graduate moved home for
one and a half months and and in each
case they had jobs and in each case we
had a plan for them to move on and in
each case when they started having the
electricity for their home deducted from
their own checking account and when they
went to the grocery store all of the
groceries in their house came out of
their checking account in every case I
watched all three of my grown children
emotionally mature over the next 60 days
right it changes them right it changes
them it's just different when mommy's
not there to clean their underwear yeah
yeah I know it's good for them oh I hear
what you're saying but she pulls up the
old heartstrings say no well I want to
go back to college and well that's good
you should yeah why you have a roommate
and you got a job it's an awesome idea
okay so when did you leave home I left
home probably around 19
yeah I was 19 when I left home to go to
college never went back not sure I was
welcome just kidding me not really
really helped my mom yeah yeah yeah I
mean we were carrying emotional the
adulthood around and those in those
decades yeah and and we've got you know
you know it it's just you know it the
good news is is you have a good
relationship with your kids and so you
know you're not calling me up going this
one's coming in here hell raisin doing
drugs and all this stuff and you didn't
tell me all that this is actually a good
kid there good good kid yeah which makes
it hard to miss giving us a little bit
of an issue but he's straightening out
now it makes it harder though I mean if
there are bad kids would be easier kick
them out you know and when Denise oldest
would move back home we love having
Denise in the house she's actually handy
to have around she cleans up stuff you
know I mean it was awesome having her
back but it wasn't good for her right
one good for her right as much as we
didn't mind her being there and we
didn't we really didn't but it was just
it was it I watched their emotional
maturity shift dramatically within 60 to
90 days of cleaning their own underwear
buying their own groceries and paying
their own line
and so if you want to have them pay rent
for six months while you're heading
towards that then you give them that
rent back to help them get started
that's fine
help them get on a budget coach um show
them how to live show them how to look
at their income versus their out go help
them call the electric company for the
apartment complex they're looking at and
ask what the actual light bill has been
you know learn about that look at
roommates help them screen their
roommate if you want to I don't care get
the cost cut down but find an old friend
from college an old friend from high
school that they can move in with whose
parents also want them to move out
you know gang up on these people but you
know that's the thing and no I
we never charged our kid rent but we did
require behaviors out of them that led
them to leave that was the rent that
they paid on a budget looking into the
future thinking making plans of like
grown-ups do and I'm really glad I did
and I'm really proud of my kids and
that's one of the results are one of the
reasons I'm proud of them so you know I
I'm afraid that you know your case is
fine you're not anything wrong it's not
craziness it in your world wasn't in my
world either but we folks we've got a
whole society for these people that
won't leave home and then we have a
whole society full of emotionally
stunted growth as a result bunch of
little children walking around in twenty
seven-year-old bodies this is the Dave
Ramsey show